[Music]
it's seven o'clock which means you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster a vaccine
milestone reached
and the rollout of the next stage
beginning but just when
might we start to see those different
lockdown restrictions these
will be asking the health secretary in
just a few minutes time
indeed it is a show practice with voices
from the vaccine frontline this morning
we'll be speaking to one of the
country's top vaccination officials
plus the national medical director of
the nhs
will also be chatting to the world
health organization also ahead
love this dancing his way to fitness and
happiness
i'm going to be speaking to the 85 year
old alan beatty
whose online tap dancing classes are
helping to keep people
all over the world on their toes it is
monday the 15th of february
the vaccine rollout rolls on with more
than a million new letters sent out
as we begin phase two still we are also
asking when might those
different lockdown restrictions ease
as england's hotel quarantine plans kick
in we're live at heathrow airport to get
a first look at passengers arriving
from those red list countries
and we're live here in tel aviv in
israel at the heart of the world's most
successful
vaccine program but what could we learn
about their experiences here
tanks on the streets and shots fired at
a protest
as tensions and fears rise in myanmar
following the military coup
a picture of happiness the queen says
she's delighted as harry and megan
reveal they've got
another baby on the way
and it's looking much milder this week
but it will be unsettled with often wet
and windy conditions i'll have the
details for you later in the program
morning all it was clearly an ambitious
target
but phase two of the vaccine rollout has
begun today
after more than 15 million people
received their first coronavirus jag
meanwhile new measures come into force
at the borders today to
try to stop the import of new variants
uh let's just run you through some of
the key points of the day
well let us contact has been made with
over 1.2 million over 65 and the
clinically vulnerable
to invite them to make an appointment
for the vaccine
a similar number of invites is expected
to go out this week
today england's hotel quarantine plans
come into force
nearly 5 000 hotel rooms have been made
available with a further
58 000 on standby new checks will begin
at airports today
on passengers coming in from redless
countries we'll be live
at heathrow airport in just a few
moments uh but first
this guy's katerina vitozi reports on
that 15 million
vaccination target being achieved
to get 15 million people vaccinated in
10 weeks
this is what it takes please
this gp surgery is in west yorkshire
but the hustle and bustle you see and
the hope
you sense has been felt across the uk
a number of our patients have not left
their house since last february so the
excitement of them attending
for their vaccination we've seen tears
we've seen people anxious just
wanting to get life back to normal 15
million people it's such a large number
it can be difficult to visualize so
perhaps this will help
15 million people is the entire
population of london
it's everyone living in birmingham
edinburgh and the entire
population of wales that's 15 million
people who've either been offered a
first dose the majority have accepted it
and some have even had it twice and it's
been done by setting up mass vaccination
centres like this one in glasgow
by pharmacies operating like clinics
heading out with one astrozenica vial by
gps delivering vaccines by bike to the
vulnerable
or by bus to the uncertain hello my name
is
here having in various sites encourages
different aspects of the population who
naturally don't always come for vaccines
very easily
but having in a more familiar location
really helps them
feel confident we should live up the
road so it
even if i was having a bad day we knew
we could we could get here
there's also been an army of volunteers
some from medical backgrounds
others just wanting to help the nhs i
had a major car crash
18 months ago um by all accounts wasn't
survivable on the day
it's been it's been quite a journey um
i've had to learn to walk again
and my feet were very crushed but for me
to be able to give something back
is just phenomenal and with the four
most vulnerable groups reached
attention turns to those who are next my
husband's
um extremely vulnerable so we've been
kind of extra restricted
my granddaughter has cystic fibrosis so
we've kept away from hair a lot so
that hope for for us is you know we're
dying to get out the door and do
something freedom normality
hope that is what the vaccine means to
most
and what it might bring to all
katherine overtopsy sky news
uh to the health secretary in just a
moment i hope but still to come on the
show this morning i'm going to be
meeting
the man leading leading the military's
support to the uk's vaccine rollout
brigadier phil prosser joining us on the
program at half past seven
at quarter to eight i will be speaking
to the world health organization's
special covert 19 envoy doctor david
nabarro
i'll be asking him whether vaccine
passports are the way
to reopen international travel
at five past eight we'll be speaking to
professor anthony hardin of the
vaccination and immunization committee
about the next steps of the rollout
baraz trails very pleased to say joining
us once again on the programme the
health secretary at matt hancock
minister great to have you on this
morning and i just have a
quick check on the feed from the red
room to see if you are still dancing
that little jig you spoke about at the
weekend like i think it's fair to say
you and i have had our run-ins on this
program over recent weeks and months
credit where credit is due well done we
hit the 15 million target
thank you we i'm really really proud of
the team we hit it two days early
and right across the whole of the uk
managing to ensure that everybody in
groups one to four is
is offered a jab and um got
15 million jabs done i mean but you know
you say that i
i dance a little jig that was referring
specifically to you know when members of
my family
got vaccinated and i i know that for you
know for millions of people this is such
an
emotional moment because it's the moment
that
protects us and also is just a little
step towards freedom for us all
yeah yeah i would of course participate
in a similar little jig myself members
of my own family have
have had the vaccine but i think there
are probably offcom regulations
against such a display at this time in
the morning i suppose the problem for
you if indeed there is a problem
is that one target is done and it's
straight on to the next one
isn't it you know the end of april
becomes the next important date in the
vaccine timetable
yes that's absolutely right there's you
know no rest for the wicked and
we're straight on to the next groups so
the letters have already been
sent to over a million over 65 year olds
inviting them to come forward and also
the
next group after that is those who have
underlying health conditions
and are carers so there's a
a huge program obviously underway uh
rolling out to to invite the next group
of people
to be vaccinated and at the same time
from next month we have
obviously the second jabs of
all the people who've come since january
to
to make sure that those happen on time
because they have to be within a
specific
12-week time period so there's still
obviously a
huge amount of work to do but we we have
managed to vaccinate
the those who are most vulnerable and
the single thing i'd pick out if i may
in the program in terms of
you know how it's going is the uptake is
much higher than we expected
over 90 percent for all of the over 70s
uh over over 97 now for
for people in their late 70s which is
the group where the uptake is highest at
the moment
um and so whilst going to
younger age groups and going broader we
will also
keep going back to those who are most
vulnerable
to offer them a job if they haven't come
forward yet because because getting that
uptake
to as high as it possibly can be is
really important for protecting us all
a metric identified by you and and
others is absolutely critical to the way
in which we come out of this is of
course
mortality in in those top two most most
vulnerable groups that will give us the
clearest indication that the vaccination
program is
is working are we at that point yeah
have we got any data that suggests that
that is
already happening i mean we have been
vaccinating i think since what roughly
second week of december now yes we've
been vaccinating since the
8th of december that's when uh margaret
keenan got her
jab um and the uh the signs
are that thankfully the number of deaths
is
falling and um and and has been now
coming down
for a few weeks uh it's too early
to say whether that is directly due to
the vaccination program
yet in those first couple of weeks in
december
the numbers were relatively small you
know we're going at half a million a day
now whereas in december we did a million
in the whole of december from the eighth
through to
through to new year um so it's too early
to
to be able to measure the direct impact
but of course we're
we're we're looking at that and we can
see
overall that the number of cases is
coming down
sharply the numbers in hospitals is
coming down but it is still too high
you know on the latest count there's
still 23 000 people in hospital with
covet
i i wonder then if you might speak
directly to members of your
your own parliamentary party the the
coveted recovery group
they again are making the point look if
we keep up with the pace of vaccination
and everyone is expecting we are given
how well we've done so far
by the end of april if we have
vaccinated those those
most vulnerable groups why are they
wrong
to link that moment to the end of
lockdown
well we we've got to watch the data and
i look i i talk to um at
mark harper and others all the time
because
everybody wants to get out of this as
safe
as quickly as we safely can and both as
quickly but also as safely
are important and that's what everybody
agrees with
you know and the question is a judgment
of
how quickly and safely
how quickly we can do that safely that's
the judgment that we'll be making
this week looking at the data ahead of
the prime minister setting out the
roadmap
on the 22nd so a week from today
so these are the judgments that will be
made that will be made
this week and we'll talk to everybody to
um
you know who has an input into that
debate because it's a very important and
uh fine judgment
can we then be specific when we say
we're looking at the data
which data will be using as as
absolutely
critical to to the relaxation i mean we
look at a couple of key
moments in our pandemic response july
the 4th last year when pubs restaurants
hairdressers
reopened we were recording i think it
was 650 cases roughly
last when last non-essential shops
reopened we were recording around
1 000 at new cases yesterday it was you
know pretty much 11 000.
we are a country mile are we not from
the type of relaxation that the covered
the covered recovery group wants to see
well there is of course there's a
there's a long way to go and
you know in a way the most important
message remains
the message for everybody to stay at
home and abide by the rules i mean it's
pretty
you know it's it's pretty uh
extraordinary and very positive how
how people are following those rules
even after all this time
and i'm very grateful to it to everybody
uh in fact the support for the measures
that we've taken
is just as high as it was uh in the
first lockdown and you can see that the
number of people who are following the
rules is just as high as it always has
been
but i know how how you know the
pressures that they bring
of course i do and um so you're right
there's a long way to go
there's too many people still in
hospital and
sadly deaths are still the number of
deaths each day is still
is still too high but it's these
measures
hospitalizations and deaths as well as
of course you know the success of the
uh of the rollout the vaccine rollout
which is going
really well um that we'll be looking at
and making sure we're vigilant to ensure
we don't
have a a new variant that blows the
whole thing
uh makes the whole thing more difficult
um and um
and we you know that's why it's so
important that we're
that we take tough measures against uh
new variants as well
sure once again though monday morning
you go through the papers as i'm sure
uh as i'm sure you do the same as i and
there are any number of measures that
are being floated there this morning
you know being able to meet up with your
grandparents you know being able to sit
the friend on a park bench
the possibility of you know
self-catering holidays in
in april i mean can you confirm or deny
any of those i mean actually just on the
holidays thing you told us last week you
were off to cornwall
he didn't tell us when i'm wondering if
that might give me an indication of when
i could be booking
um no the these decisions will be made
this week and the prime minister will
announce them on
on monday week i know there's a lot of
speculation of course there is these are
important this speculation is not
helpful i mean either
shouldn't we be part of this
conversation do we can we not be trusted
to be part of this conversation and by
we i mean the
the population as a whole well you are
part of the conversation because you're
asking me questions about it
and um lots of people are making their
uh
their views and their preferences uh
clear
there's a debate in the newspapers i
think that's
totally reasonable given the scale of
these judgments um
and we will we'll look at the data and
take
advice and the prime minister will set
that all out on monday
sure but okay another aspect of the
response which
i feel kind of is parallel to the point
i was making there vaccine passports
you know we had the vaccine passports
weren't going to be happening that was
nadine's highway
we heard that they were a matter perhaps
for the private sector we then heard
from the foreign secretary yesterday
at saying the matter is under
consideration which of those is it
and and do you see why some people are
somewhat confused
you know you know the foreign secretary
it can't get his words right when it
comes to whether or not we've got a
vaccine passport on the way
how how can the rest of us cope well
let me tell you exactly what the
situation is there are
some countries around the world that are
considering
bringing in rules saying that you can
only travel
if you've been vaccinated these aren't
in place yet
but there are countries that are
actively floating
this idea and proposing it and in that
case
it will be important for people from the
uk to be able to show
whether or not they've been vaccinated
in order to travel
and so we're working with countries
around the world
on a on the basis for this and how
that vaccine certification can happen
in a way that can be assured because
obviously
you know if if you're a country that's
saying you can only come in if you've
had a vaccine
you want you'd want to have confidence
that a person saying they've had a
vaccine
has had a vaccine and we want brits
to be able to travel to to those
countries
and therefore enable brits to be able to
demonstrate
their vaccine status and so that sort of
vaccine certification is something that
we're talking to our
international counterparts about and i
you know it is and there's there's
people who are arguing that that
is the right way to have safe global
travel again once uh you know because
obviously that's very restricted at the
moment and that's obviously an important
piece of work
what just briefly because i know you're
about to you we need to let you go but
one of the
having to prove your vaccination status
not to access government services
but to access services provided by the
private sector
do i need a vaccine passport to go to
the pub when they open
that we do not have plans to do that as
i say there is this international work
going on because of the
you know because if other countries
require that we want to allow brits to
be able to
uh to travel to those countries in the
same way
that for parts of sub-saharan africa you
need to have a yellow fever certificate
i know i've got a crumpled old yellow
fever certificate uh from uh from
uh from when i uh last traveled to
sub-saharan africa so
um that is a uh these things have
happened
um and and still happen in parts of the
world and obviously
we'd want to be able to facilitate that
sort of vaccine certification
but it isn't anything we're planning to
introduce here
at minister we do have to let you go
gotta say we won't talk about the six
nations result at the weekend but i'm
sure you'd be very pleased to say that i
hear that i took your advice my boy and
i we're out in the park playing rugby
this weekend
uh matt hancock great to have you in the
program this morning thanks for having
me
uh once again our political
correspondent kate mccann uh listening
into our chat with the health secretary
morning kate uh
what struck you i think it was
interesting i mean there was loads of
good news in there wasn't that
important to start with that i think 15
million vaccinated is a great target
matt hancock said we move on to the next
one which is of course
the end of april really positive news
for anyone out there this morning who's
watching wondering when they might be
able to leave the house feel comfortable
seeing family again
feel comfortable going to the shops
again for lots of people so that's great
news
but i think it's more difficult when you
start to ask about how
things are opened up and you did get
some clarity from matt hancock there
and what exactly they're looking at when
they talk about this data
he was talking about hospitalizations
number of people in hospitals
still 23 000 people there and we know
that people with covered can end up in
hospital for a long time so that might
take some time to ease off
also about mortality how many people are
dying from the virus
and key will be vaccinations how well
that goes to
any issues with supply could throw that
of course and also then he mentioned in
there too
new variants a key area today will be
quarantine hotels at the border
if they work well that would be positive
for the government well we should have a
rough idea by this time tomorrow for now
okay thanks very much indeed
uh well as kate was just mentioning
there england's
quarantine hotels will be receiving
their first guest today but there are
some concerns about the plans heathrow
airport say they're worried as cues at
the border in recent days
have been almost five hours long scans
millionaire veselninovich is
for us this morning uh good to see you
up there i can't see you now milena good
to see you
um of course we are a few hours away
from from the first flight that we'll be
sending people to
to quarantine and we know that there
have been some concerns expressed
by heathrow airport amongst others
yeah an extra border police has been
deployed to try to deal with that issue
but i can tell you neil that the first
passengers from these
red list countries are now in baggage
hall waiting to pick up their bags and
then they will be escorted
through these doors behind me to a bus
which will take them to one of these
quarantine hotels i'm also told that
they were queuing
in a different line in order to get to
border control
to other passengers in order to try to
isolate them
as much as possible really and before
they
set off they would have had to have
pre-booked
one of these quarantine packages at a
cost of one thousand
seven hundred and fifty pounds per
person if they
get here without having one booked well
they're liable for applying up to four
thousand pounds and they'll still have
to pay for the package
anyway now uh heathrow where i am
is just one of five airports where
you're allowed to arrive to
if you're coming from one of these red
list countries if you turn up anywhere
else
you are liable for a fine of up to ten
thousand
pounds and you'll still have to pay for
transport to the next port of entry
that is allowed it's very expensive now
once people are collected and they're
escorted to
their buses and they're taking to these
hotels they'll be confined
to their rooms if for example they want
to go
exercise well that's at the discretion
of the security staff so it's
not guaranteed and what we don't know is
that if they are allowed to exercise
whether that would be in the gym or
perhaps
somewhere outdoors in a courtyard it's
not exactly whether for it right
now but i don't know we'll see there are
small exemptions that just
holiers from portugal who are allowed to
come here without quarantining
as well as diplomats
malena thanks very much indeed
uh big day in terms of vaccinations i'm
pleased to say we've got a number of
uh specials on the rollout uh rolling
out themselves at one o'clock
at 4 p.m and 8 p.m on skies in fact the
8 o'clock special
taking a closer look at why there's that
issue of
vaccine hesitancy among some parts of
the black and
asian communities
now armored vehicles have rolled through
the streets of myanmar this morning
after security forces opened fire during
a protest
at a power plant let's get the very
latest from our southeast asia
correspondent siobhan robbins at morning
siobhan
what on earth is going on in myanmar at
the moment those shots fired at the
protests seem to
to follow that that uptick which we were
commenting on at the
at the tail end of last week in terms of
the response from the military
yeah a really tense weekend again in
myanmar so we've seen these armoured
vehicles roll into cities including
yangon and sitwe and rakhine state but
also
last night in kachin state protesters
who were
demonstrating outside a power plant were
dispersed
by force with authorities using water
cannon and rubber bullets and one of the
residents who was there
told us what she saw
the security forces started to disperse
the crowd they were opening fire using
rubber bullets
there were so many shots they also used
tear gas and some people got hit in the
head and legs and were injured
the military do seem to be clamping down
at the moment and it's not helped by the
fact that there are so many rumors which
of course have got worse
because again overnight the internet was
turned off uh between
one and nine in the morning so people
really worried about what's happening
during those internet blackouts and at
the same time ansang su chi who was
expected to appear in court today
has been remanded for another two days
with her lawyer
who i've spoken to several times saying
that it's
difficult for him to get access to her
he is trying to access her but we
should get another update about her
situation on wednesday
but i don't think anyone in the country
is expecting her to be released
siobhan many thanks
now food and delivery bosses are urging
the government
to reintroduce the eat out to help out
scheme when restrictions are eased
the return of the scheme is one of a
number of recommendations to support the
hospitality industry sent out in a
letter to the prime minister
science by delivery and 330 restaurant
partners including pizza hut
and itsu
an nhs study has found that ct scanning
can detect
70 of lung cancers at an early stage
experts are now calling for routine
scans to be offered to smokers
and ex-smokers which could save
thousands of lives every year
the father of the missing chef claudia
lawrence has died without
ever knowing what happened to his
daughter
peter lawrence lost his life in york age
74
following a short illness his death
comes 12 years after his daughter
claudia went missing
police believe the 35 year old was
murdered but her body has never been
found
well let's return to the race to
vaccinate against coronavirus
and head to israel which of course has
been a couple of steps ahead of us
throughout the pandemic
uh we've got some news from there this
morning uh on their vaccination
program itself uh let's speak to our
middle east correspondent at mark stone
inside a hospital
in tel aviv forest good to see you mark
um as you mentioned
and what we describe as the openers that
bid at the top of the program
big question when we look towards israel
is you know what lessons can we learn
from them
at the stage that they're at in the
vaccination rollout
yeah morning neil israel's been ahead of
the the experience curve i suppose you
could say over the course of this uh
pandemic
and it's sometimes been positive and
sometimes been very negative i mean they
they
locked down very quickly back in march
last year but then they came out of that
lockdown far too quickly with
disastrous consequences a massive spike
in the number of cases but as we've been
reporting over the course of the past
few weeks or so the vaccination program
here and you can see just inside one
hospital
is underway now and they are vaccinating
many many hundreds of thousands of
people at this hospital alone 103 000
people
vaccinated so far but have a look at
this this is worrying potentially
empty seats they've seen a massive
fall-off in the number of people
willing to get a vaccination they want
90 of the country to be vaccinated
it's not happening at the moment they
had lots of uptake early on
but this could be a glimpse into to our
future
as we try and you were talking to matt
hancock earlier on as we try to
vaccinate more and more people
uh they are finding here that younger
people are less willing
to be vaccinated if we squeeze through
here i want to introduce
professor ronnie gamzu thank you for
talking to us you're live on sky i
i guess we could sort of call you um
israel's chris witty who is our
the advisor to the government at one
stage you were advising benjamin
netanyahu it's a rotating role
but you're also the director of this
hospital how are things
yes we are now continuing the
the vaccination plan we are reaching
now almost more than 4 million
reaching almost you know more than two
and a half million two doses of vaccines
and this is a small country we should
point out nine million people
of course almost 40 percent
and i must say that we see the effect of
the
vaccines and you know we are admitting
each day around 20 severe patient
no one of them almost no one of them is
after the vaccination all of them are
non-vaccinated
meaning that the vaccine is really
effective and is working
and this is really the plan to go out
of the epidemic and this is what really
is happening now
but the problem and we can see empty
chairs out there the problem is you are
seeing now a drop off in the number of
people willing to have the vaccine
you know what if you look at the sick
fans
they are continuing the dynamics here we
are looking ahead
and completing many other people that
are you know not the regular people are
under the sick fans
we are vaccinating their all the
diplomats around the tel aviv area we
are vaccinating all the illegal
residents
that do not have sick funds so we are
looking at
each person trying to attract them and
you know what
relatively we are we are succeeding and
this is what's happening
also in the young people all right
professor thank you very much for
joining us and they're using a carrot
and stick policy here now so the health
minister
is proposing and you were talking to
matt hancock about this neil the health
minister is proposing
that if you haven't been vaccinated and
you can't prove it you won't be allowed
to go to the
to to the bars shops restaurants gyms
you will be banned from entering pretty
draconian
but they're looking at it very seriously
here as an option to get the country
back to normal hello mark many thanks
indeed
more from mark through the day ah now
you may have noticed a little bit of
news this morning a new royal baby
is coming uh the queen says she's
delighted
uh joining us now our royal
correspondent at rhiannon mills
morning rhiannon so a man and a woman
are having a second baby
yes i suspect there'll be a few people
around the world who'll be a little more
excited
than that certainly the pregnancy
announcement last night
came in a way that we wouldn't usually
expect from members of the royal family
with that very
intimate photograph that is splashed
right across all of the front pages this
morning
harry sitting there on the grass with
his bare feet
megan lying with her head on his lap
and yeah they could not be happier to
share the world share with the world
that archie
is going to be a big brother i have to
say last night it does seem that the
the way they announced it did slightly
get the palace on the hop
a little bit it took a bit of time uh
for us to hear that the queen and the
rest of the family were delighted that's
despite the fact that we told that harry
and megan had told them
that they were expecting a baby but i
think it shows that the couple really
want to control the way that they
release their their news
now now that they've stepped away as
senior working
royals but yes all babies are special
but this one is certainly going to be
unique the first of the queen's
great grandchildren to be born abroad
despite uh it will be eighth in line to
the throne
ryan many thanks indeed uh now it has
been
well a weekend of fairly changeable
weather and it looks like we might start
to be easing out of the cold spell nas
is here to tell us whether or not that
is true i mean i saw
reports in one of the papers this
morning that next weekend we could be
seen temperatures as high as
15 degrees celsius yep it is going to be
an
incredibly mild week for most places
it's already mild out there this morning
except for parts of the northeast it's a
bit chilly there
but with the mild conditions as well we
are going to see rather wet
and windy conditions
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so much milder conditions
expected this week temperatures
could rise up into the mid teens in some
places
over the next few days but it is going
to be often wet
and windy in fact this morning there are
spells of rain across southern and
eastern parts of england
and there are showers out towards the
west particularly across the northwest
and it's a breezy morning but the winds
coming from that mild
southerly flow hence the fact it's not a
cold start but it is still quite chilly
across parts of the northeast of
england where there could be some frost
perhaps even the risk of ice
and through the day we'll see that rain
clear from the southeast of england
there are murky conditions this morning
as well that may be quite slow to lift
and clear
and may linger in some spots into this
afternoon but otherwise we'll see bright
or sunny spells developing for most
places this afternoon
and we'll see the continuation of
blustery showers particularly
heavy across parts of the northwest of
the uk and ireland it also turns
increasingly windy across the west later
some gales likely to develop as we head
towards this evening
as rain spreads to the south west of
england and to western parts of ireland
and both these areas of rain will be
moving north and eastwards overnight
with heavy downpours so at some point
through the night it's going to be
rather wet once again
and it will be windy with showers
following in from the west tomorrow that
rain
clears from the northeast but it will
take some time for it to clear from
southern and eastern parts of england
elsewhere there'll be brighter sunny
spells but blustery showers again
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now thanks very much indeed let's take
you back to my conversation
with the health secretary a little
earlier on the program matt hancock said
i will despite the current success of
the vaccine rollout scheme
there's still a long way to go before
the government can ease restrictions he
said
the government is pulling together all
the information before making any
decisions
but he also mentioned that for now
people should
still stay at home to avoid spreading
the virus
there's a long way to go and you know in
a way
the most important message remains the
message for everybody to
stay at home and abide by the rules i
mean it's pretty
you know it's it's pretty uh
extraordinary and very positive
how how people are following those rules
even after all this time
and i'm very grateful to it to everybody
uh in fact the support for the measures
that we've taken
is just as high as it was uh in the
first
lockdown and you can see that the
number of people who are following the
rules is just as high as it always has
been
but i know how how you know the
pressures that they bring of course i do
and um so you're right there's a long
way to go
uh well as we always do let's remind
ourselves as to the latest
data on coronavirus here in the uk
10 972 new confirmed cases of covert 19
were recorded in the most recent 24-hour
period
a further 258 people have lost their
lives within 28 days
of testing positive and that is the
lowest
daily number we've had in 2021 still we
shouldn't
we shouldn't forget the fact that brings
the uk total to 117
166 but as we've been mentioning on the
show the big news
more than 15 million first doses of the
vaccine
have been administered
uh right at the beginning of the vaccine
rollout program the government
brought in the armed forces to help
organize the logistics of the massive
operation
so far it appears to have been very
successful
all of which means it's rather handy
that we can now speak to brigadier phil
prosser
the commander of the 101 logistic
brigade has been leading the military
support
to the vaccine rollout since november
brigadier
great to have you on the programme this
morning um and i wonder if we might from
you
have a perhaps an expression of pride at
just how instrumental
uh your men and women have been in
ensuring the government hit that 15
million target
yeah it's been an amazing feat and i'm
really proud to be part of this
truly amazing team i think it's
important to say that i
coordinate the military contribution to
this team but it is very much
nhs led under some amazing leadership
who um
who have done some amazing things to
really hit this target over the
uh over the last few weeks from the very
start it's
it's been an unprecedented operation by
scalar complexity about getting this
knee vaccine
into the arms of those who need it most
as quickly as possible so we face
challenges along the way
but it's a real um it's a real point for
reflection and celebration achieving
this first milestone
certainly is um i wonder if you might
just be able to elaborate a little for
for
for some of our viewers who are perhaps
puzzled at that request to to bring in
the armed forces as to
what exactly it is that you you have all
been you've all been doing i will
confess
myself my eyes were opened the first
time i was embedded with the british
army out in afghanistan
so much of what our armed forces do
revolves
around logistics and deployment so this
was absolutely right up your alley
yeah it is and we um we excel at dealing
with
the frictions and chaos of war but it
doesn't have to be
conflict a war it can be any operation
where that uncertainty can lead to um
that
uncertainty uh complex requirement for
plans complex problems
uh can really play to the strengths of
the military
and i think it's been something that we
can really celebrate is the coming
together of two
world-class institutions the nhs who
designed
and uh configured to protect the nation
through
world-leading healthcare and the
military who do this operational
planning and uncertainty
uh facing complex times and the coming
together of these two world cast
institutions is something really to
celebrate
i think what the military have brought
in the initial phase is as we went from
the planning phase into the delivery we
worked alongside the nhs to help
understand exactly what was required to
go through the analysis phase
in order to build resilience planning uh
brazilian plan sorry
and then as we switch the planning phase
we brought what we're famous for the
discipline and tempo
to add that real pace to everything that
we were doing here
and i think the complexity shouldn't be
underestimated you know some of these
vaccines were
are really complex to handle we didn't
know how the
system it never been tested before this
was you know the largest but that it
this is the largest vaccination program
we've delivered and we've never done it
before so
it was a real and remains a real period
of learning as we go
speak to them a little bit about the
challenges where have the greatest
challenges been faced
i think there's three challenges that uh
have been involved in the early phases
of this and that's trying to go as
quickly as we can
to get it across the country equally and
to get it into
some of the small communities uh where
their risk is highest such as in
care homes so those three challenges
have gone as quickly as possible
getting it into the arms of those who
need it most and doing it equally across
the country each come at a cost to each
other
so the plan has to be constantly toggled
to make sure we do that because what we
don't want is
65 year olds in london getting the
vaccine before 80 or 85 year olds in
newcastle
so getting the distribution plan
absolutely right has been critical
and also making sure we are agile enough
to go into
small communities such as those in care
homes last week we spend a lot of time
going into housebound patients
to make sure that if people can't come
to large vaccination sites we can take
the vaccinations
to them so toggling those three things
has really been
the greatest challenge but as i say and
as you said right
up front you know achieving this first
milestone has been a real success
and being part of this amazing team and
watching them achieve these things has
has been a real honor to be part of i
know that we've
hit that 50 million target and now look
towards the target of 32 million
everyone in those
those most vulnerable groups this is not
the end of the armed forces involvement
in this program i suspect
no we'll stay here as long as the nhs
need us and as long as the country
need us to help in this amazing
operation we've now achieved
offers to cohort one to four we move on
to cohort five to nine now which we'll
hope to
complete probably by early may
but that doesn't mean we'll leave kill
one one to four behind and we need to go
back to make sure that we've reached
uh as many of those as possible and to
maximize those uptake levels
but the the military are here for as
long as the nhs need us and
and all my team and the troops on the
ground are really proud to be part of
this amazing operation
and we're all very grateful for your
participation uh brigadier prosser great
to have you on the show this morning
thanks being with us
great to have you on the show this
morning great thank you
well let's turn our attention uh back to
at the domestic political situation
get the view from the labour side of the
chamber the shadow education secretary
kate green
joining us once again on the program ms
green great to have you on um
obviously so much to talk around
education schools and so on
but but just a word from you the
government said they would get
to the 15 million most vulnerable it
appears that they have done so that this
is a moment to mark
absolutely a moment to celebrate and to
express our thanks to
the nhs the volunteers the scientists
and researchers everybody who has
contributed to this achievement um and
i'm really delighted that the
vaccination program
is rolling out and reaching people we've
all been desperate
uh for it to uh progress and it's great
to see that we've hit this
15 million target there is obviously a
bit of a worry now about
people who haven't come forward for the
vaccination who
who are eligible and i think we have to
have a really big push now
to reach out to people who may be
doubtful who need some more reassurance
because obviously
until we get um these four priority
groups and other vulnerable people
vaccinated and eventually
everybody vaccinated we can't be fully
safe and so
it is important that the government
redoubles its efforts to reach those
people at the same time as
as continuing with the vaccination
program for for everyone else
indeed and of course successes in the
vaccination rollout do not mean that
people who are
suffering in our communities that
suffering comes to to an immediate end
just on that topic today labour's
calling on a transformation for support
for families tell us a little bit about
it
i'm sorry neil i didn't quite catch that
sorry the labour party today is calling
for a transformation
for families uh children facing a bit of
a postcode lottery when it comes to that
half-term support
yeah absolutely so what we've got as
half term stocks for many schools up and
down the country this
week is um that's the free school meals
program
of course isn't actually applying this
health farm and
families have been told that they'll
have to rely on the winter support grant
that is administered by
local authorities there are a couple of
problems with that first of all
that winter support grant fund isn't
just for school food it's got a lot of
pressures on it and
so families are going to have to apply
for us and hope that there's enough
money in the pot if they're
worrying about how to feed their
children um we're also concerned that
the government's guidance to local
authorities about this fund
actually says it shouldn't be used to
replicate or replace school food
programs and now the government is
apparently saying well yes it should be
so with that kind of confusion i think
it's really quite concerning as we start
half term families will be
worrying about how they're going to feed
their children and i just can't
understand why
the school food program that's been put
in place for for the summer and
christmas holidays and easter
it can't be extended to half terms too
and why the government's just refusing
to do that
in terms of children returning to school
march the 8th of course it remains the
date that everyone's eyes are focused on
in terms of england wales going back
slightly earlier i mean is there an
argument
for the government in england to look
again at whether or not we could get
kids back into school somewhat earlier
than that second week in march it's
important
that um the government is very cautious
i mean what we saw of course was that
the welsh labor government was actually
quicker to bring in
the lockdowns last year the circuit
breaker and so we're on slightly
different paths between wales and
england
but i do think that it's really
important that the government here
learns the lessons when it's released
lockdowns too quickly in previous
months and and make sure that it's
properly examined the data
is absolutely clear that the metrics
that it's going to rely on and we need
to know what those are is it
fewer hospitalizations is it less
transmission in the community for
example
won't be harmed uh by the way in which
they begin to release the lockdown but
clearly we've always said that we
we do think those need to be the first
fully to real but we're desperate
uh to see children safely back in class
i just think it's important the
government
takes its time to keep all options on
the table
and if that means bringing children back
um on the on and after the eighth of
march perhaps on a staggered basis
uh or perhaps in a rota system those
options need to be kept on the table too
which would be the worst option for our
children
for the schools to to reopen at the
beginning of march and then at some
point over the next few weeks to close
again
or that we simply bite the bullet and
push
forward with remote learning for the
majority of the school year
i think it's a very difficult balance
and obviously the chopping and changing
that we've seen
during last term when children would go
into school and then bubbles would be
sent home again sometimes children were
repeatedly in and out of school perhaps
four or five even six times that was
very damaging and disruptive
to their learning and very very
difficult for parents working parents
uh to manage so remote learning is a
good way of stepping into the gap until
children can be
properly and securely back in school but
of course we're still waiting
for the government to deliver hundreds
of thousands of the promised laptops
to families that don't have the digital
resources they need for children
to be able to study at home and of
course we do know that
um there is the possibility that from
time to time children will have to go
home and study again remotely for a
period if perhaps
somebody in their own family is um
unwell and they have to isolate with
them
so it is really important the government
presses on with this laptops program
it gets those digital resources
delivered as quickly as possible
but i i would say that yeah you're right
now once we get children back into
school we really want them to stay there
and that's why it's important the
government takes a cautious
but a sustainable approach um and that
it's absolutely transparent with us
about the basis in which it's taking the
decision about the return after the 8th
of march
okay green good to see you thanks for
joining us once again thank you very
much
well as the vaccine rollout continues
among many
of the world's countries what can we
learn
from others uh pleased to say dr david
nomaro the world health organization's
special envoy for the global covert 19
response
joins us on the program david great to
have you on the show
once again and we so often dive straight
into taking the minutiae of country's
responses to to
covet pandemic i just want to try
something different this morning of
course
many smiles here in the united kingdom
as we've hit
15 million first doses how are you
feeling just in general
about the way in which the world is is
responding to covid19 are you positive
are you happy you're always smiling in
this program i just want to know
how you actually feel about it all
well actually i feel pretty good i have
in front of me
the daily report of numbers of cases of
covid
reported from around the world and i i
don't want to push it up to the camera
because it's not easy to see
but over the period since mid december
really
all over the world the numbers have been
coming down
a bit like what we see in the uk which
has been a dramatic reduction in cases
but globally also it's the the daily
numbers the weekly numbers have just
been dropping
why is that it's really is because
people
have kind of worked out how they're
going to get on with their lives
but at the same time stop this virus
from spreading
it's absolutely amazing what's going on
but of course
once people start to move around again
then everybody's
really quite impatient to get moving
the the challenge will be to keep those
numbers down and stop them coming up
surging up yet again uh they are i'm
afraid
still rising in other parts of the world
in latin america
and parts of africa we've got some
really nasty situations
uh that are that are causing us some
disturbance but the overall picture
neil is one of of really extraordinary
efforts being made
and good results so if we can keep it up
then we can get on with our lives we'll
see what i mean
yeah well i'm running out of fingers to
cross i have to say david but let's
let's focus exactly that but look
you mentioned there of course that there
are parts of the world which are not not
able
to keep pace uh with the united kingdom
and you can and you can certainly
understand why that might be all of
which means we need to be really careful
at guarding our borders from potential
new variants
all of which suggest that we will be
needing to see some form of
international vaccine passport
at some point in the not too distant
future
i'm absolutely certain that in the
coming few months
we will get a lot of movement on what
other conditions
around which people are easily able to
move from place to place
some sort of vaccine certificate no
doubt will be important
but the other thing that's necessary is
for different countries to have a pretty
clear idea
of how good the systems are in each side
of a journey
because if you if you know that you've
got the same sort of
quality of systems to deal with disease
for example in a part of europe that you
might want to go to for holiday
and that's similar to what's happening
in your own country then
travel between the two sides creating a
bubble and so on
becomes straightforward it's very
important when it comes to
looking out for the variants as as we
call them
because this virus does change it
mutates quite
quite frequently and some of the
mutations
only a few of them are quite worrisome
we call them variants of concern
so you're so right we've got to be quite
vigilant from now
looking forward both inside our
countries because variants can appear
inside our own borders but also because
sometimes
variants can be brought by people from
other places
that's going to be with us for the
foreseeable future because
even when much higher percentages of the
uk population are vaccinated there will
still be these
worrying moments when perhaps the
aversion of the virus appears that can
break through the dependencies provided
by the vaccine and that becomes
something we have to look out for so
it's looking good
everybody it's looking really good the
british situation
but there is i'm afraid going to be a
longer term period of continued hard
work
especially to find ways to come out of
the current
very very strong lockdown situation that
uk and other countries are in to a more
relaxed situation
and we have to make that change with
quite a lot of care
presumably part of the way in which we
get the world out of all of this is
those industrialized nations
like the united kingdom which have
over-ordered in terms of vaccines
that they begin to distribute that to
the rest of the world has any has much
work been done on that as yet
yes that there's a lovely scheme that's
been set up
internationally actually at the request
of all the different nations with the uk
right at the front of it called kovacs
and this is a scheme that enables
everybody in the world to benefit from
negotiated prices for these vaccines
and also to be in a position where they
can use the vaccines that have been
approved by the world health
organization
after going through rigorous safety
checks we'd like to encourage
all countries whether they're rich or
poor
to use this kovac scheme built into
kovacs
is the possibility for a country that's
managed to get hold of
enough vaccines for its own vaccination
programs
then to provide access to the pool
that can then be distributed to the rest
of the world we'd like to encourage
countries to use this scheme
it's transparent it's got all sorts of
governance
rules so that everybody knows what's
being offered but it does mean that
every country in the world gets a chance
to have a share and poor countries can
get some of their vaccine costs covered
by the wealthy countries which means
that we do
end up with a situation where even the
poorest countries in the world
can afford to immunize their health
workers particularly
and others who are at risk so appeal to
everybody
use kovacs it is a really great global
system
dr david nabarro you look after yourself
until next week talk at fernando thanks
very much
i'll come back thank you bye bye now
uh time to see how the weather is
looking this morning nice had some good
news of our own
earlier in the programme makes a change
uh how's it looking
looking much milder compared to the
recent days we've had but
it is also going to be rather wet and
windy at times
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so this week is going to be
much milder compared to recently
temperatures are going to
rise into double figures for some spots
into the mid teens
over the next few days and it's a mild
start this morning too but it is going
to be
rather unsettled this week we are seeing
spells of rain for example this morning
across the south and east of england
and uh further west there are also some
outbreaks of rain in between that it's
mostly dry
but it's not that bright at the moment
as there
are areas of misfog and low cloud
crossing england wells that will
eventually lift and clear to bright or
sunny spells this afternoon that rain
should also clear the southeast
but showers will continue across the
northwest and later rain to the
southwest and western island
with windy conditions the weather
sponsored by qatar airways